let's shift gears over a little [ __ ] to
another fondly remembered franchise the
doom multiplayer beta was was on last
weekend I think it was this week as
previously good am I got to play for the
first time properly you played it back
at quakecon last year was it oh yes oh
yeah whatever you rob you played some
over the weekend as well I played
roughly like four hours cool yeah how
many bed seems me yeah and what were
your initial impressions of it I dug it
I the pacing was nice I mean it was
different like for me is like a I like
if yes is like just much as everyone
else but like I think what I've become
tired of is like just dying immediately
right and there's something about this
game that like you know having L health
and armor scattered around was like okay
cool you get like a nice streak in
because that's always what you like
really want from a shooter is like
having a streak I mean obviously skill
needs to be a factor of it but this game
kind of prolonged like the combat I
thought that was I mean not just like
initial thoughts what's up at you play
your sort of like you played out of Halo
and Call of Duty's right now right yeah
we're definitely halo and that's much
ecology but a lot of it there's a lot of
hail on this yeah if I mean some of the
like visuals in it for me I was really I
don't know down on this going into it I
hadn't played it yet but I was kind of
worried because I'd seen a lot of the
trailers on my guy showing a lot of team
modes here and it's looking very space
marini and not a doom way more like a
halo way um and I did I did kind of
enjoy it but it feels very much like
it's stuck in some sort of limbo between
those two games so certain affinity is
developing this for it and they're the
folks who helped bungee with I think
halo 4 I guess it wasn't one dude well
they've worked on 804 and also on call
of duty ghosts as well so they're sort
of of that ilk when it comes to this
type of multiplayer and like there's a
lot of stuff which is straight up from
that type of game which is like you
there are leveling up there are loadouts
I mean you only carry two guns you can
pick whatever to they are and then
whatever sort of grenade or optional
other type of accessory I guess as well
yeah the Marling's is the one armored
ended up here since like you know like
swapping your helmet down yeah I'm
unlocking that stuff
as you level up as well as a sort of
part of it and and although it has like
you know the the doomed type weapons
they don't feel like doom but what they
felt like was kind of fine like I was
enjoying this game on its own terms but
to me it doesn't really really feel like
doom all that much what did you like I
felt like it's been months now he was
back in July that I played it there were
some like shades of quake in there
especially when it came to movement and
things like launch pads I thought those
were really fun and I and I enjoyed that
aspect of it I played just I think it
was a single mode on a single map over
and over again you know and it was in a
controlled environment but I had a lot
of fun with it like I really enjoyed the
fact that it feels like a game but I
haven't played in a while even though
like I can see where you guys are coming
from with the comparisons that are
similar between other games the what it
amounted to all the parts together felt
different enough um but I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to like play this long
term it's gonna come down to a lot of
you know how much there is to do and
whether or not it's fun to play yeah I
think the mechanics feel right for me I
like the map design that I played on but
you know limited impression and i liked
the what you talking about this sort of
momentum in it was pretty good the
mantling was kind of you're right it
feels way more quake II in that like you
know feels almost like quake you know
what's call it the hook mod you know
where you're like getting up to higher
positions that's what the mantling felt
a little bit more like and all the team
all the modes they talked about so far
and all the modes that they've shown so
far and they've shown in their trailers
as well have all been team modes which
again doesn't feel very I mean that's
not very quickie either unless you're
talking about like team arena like that
wasn't part of the sort of base level of
play in this particular arena shooter so
like like under this revenant stuff as
well as like super weird I actually hate
the revenant alright I think it's really
stupid like let it let people find guns
maybe like I know it doesn't sound like
design for that at this point but the
revenant thing is just sort of like hey
Europe he you can fly you can kill
anybody in one hit have fun yeah which
is like great if you're the revenant but
if you're not it's a horrible experience
yeah I mean like I'm a firm believer of
like power weapons on maps like halo uh
halo has always been like that that's
been a favorite thing right like
everyone comes in at the exact same
playing field so you can see that chart
in the end you'd be like that's that's
me and that's the basis of doom and
quake yeah it was like unless you're
playing like 1v1 was was map control and
getting to the railgun are getting to be
FG are getting to rocket launcher or
whatever the hell was right too I mean
to be throwing this in right like let's
be fair you do have to find it on the
map right like it's not like you choose
to be the revenant beforehand you have
to find the pentacrest transformed into
it and it is a droppable thing which at
least is good so there is some sort of
incentive for everyone else to kill
revenant but like it changes so much
more than what a weapon would change
yeah so red and dad says can't imagine
the player base on console sticking
around for too long this is kind of the
thing about this where it feels to me
like they're hitting some sort of middle
ground between people who want like a
hard like I'm not sure if there's the
audience for a hardcore arena shoot or
any more like unreal tournament doing is
saying on the pc on Alpha and I love
that and it's good fun this is seems
like it's trying to take that sort of
like arena shooter vibe I'm in marry it
with something a bit more mainstream II
right but like you said i'm not sure if
there's enough in this for like a lot of
people to stay with it for very long i
like to sample of the concept yeah but
don't want to order the full dish dang
eat that dish what do you think Rob what
are your somebody who does like playing
sort of halo call of duty on big
mainstream modern shooters online
shooters what did you think of this was
this it was like a novelty to it or was
it something you think you're gonna want
to play more of I'll definitely more of
it I I personally got a nice kick out of
like the look just based basically
picking a load of like a rocket launcher
yeah shot yeah yeah yeah I like to
change it i like things with it would
that change it up at least and then
still have that simplistic value like
yeah see the reverent was it called
again revenant revenant guy flying
around it's just like ah screw that dude
like i don't know i just want to go
around corners the shotgun I'm not have
to worry about like doling for these
these we need to talk about like those
pretty call those mods those are the
next hack so whatever I yeah didn't get
like a full like a grasp on like when
and how those operate yeah but like it
was just enough
like thing I feel like throwing in was
likely wet so it doesn't really people
can see me now or some like that when
they spawn or like now there's a guy who
wants to like have my head it's like
doing a game like yeah who personally
moon they're like almost like titanfall
burn cards but instead of like
benefiting you they sort of yeah like
all it did was like epic content timers
on the on the spawns or you could do one
which was like the person who killed you
you basically could see through [ __ ]
walls I give it a wall hack for that one
person which kind of seems unfair it's
like an affair that killed me fair and
square why am I now able to just like
run up behind them basically and more
murder them cuz you can if you get in
like two rocket shots and you're dead
right like to you know shot gunshots a
dead I don't know maybe they'll tinker a
little bit because of the beta feedback
but I did enjoy it I did I was I was
definitely playing it until like they
closed that beta i like wait what's
going on yeah oh damn love to have kept
lying but um yeah I'm definitely on the
fence as well I mean it's definitely
well said like it's in a little bit of a
limbo like on the fence like what type
of game is this like I do see that that
pole towards like progression I i really
get nowadays you know i mean like yeah
there's god like I don't know for me at
least like I do kind of want to see some
like incentive to like all right well I
want to look different like I want a
little bit of a pole toward like even
the differences were like the main
difference is minimal colors colors
which you had all at the stars basically
yeah the other ones was like you were
basically changing [ __ ] codpieces
like you couldn't no one's gonna ever
notice that like I will first layer you
would write just um just one all our
legal just keep this Jeff match right
right if you're if you look exactly the
same the puss like you know red and yeah
whatever but I don't even sure if
they're doing normal oh they better
that's match in this really all the
modes that they've shown because they
have one trailer where they literally
list all the modes they're all team base
so damn guys like God I would be shocked
I be Sean do some sort wasn't death
match okay every game it's like if a
street fighter came out it didn't have
our key all right thank you so much Mike
my heart is about to say
is coming in a second rajbhandari at
peter brown thank you as ever your time